ich glaube das muss ich zensieren
hey leute was glauben jetzt willkommen
beim ein video im heute mal wieder aus
einer etwas anderen position ich brauche
mich heute wieder meinen laptop und zwar
habe ich mir heute wieder was heftig
spektakuläres für euch einfallen lassen
und zwar habe ich euch gefragt bzw ich
habe mir erst mal so gedacht google ist
ja geil aber gibt es auch sachen die man
nicht googeln sollte und habe ich euch
gefragt nennt mir doch einfach mal
sachen die man nicht googeln sollte also
warum auch immer so halt einfach nicht
google googles nicht ich habe mir von
euch einfach mal vier begriffe
rausgesucht von dem was sie mir
geschickt habt und ja ich mache
natürlich heute trotzdem und guck mal
was bei rumkommt ich bin heftig gespannt
warum man das nicht googeln sollte oder
was daran so schlimm ist und da würde
ich aber sagen wir fangen sofort an
let's go den ersten begriff den ich mir
ausgesucht habt ist sorry biscuit also
sorry ich gucke einfach mal kurz was
heißt vergeben sorry heißt durchnässt
also durch nester kids und er war immer
toll wie biscuit hört sich als ich
eigentlich vor lecker an so wenn man
durch nester keks wird sich nicht länger
an aber sorry bist schon also das bild
ist auf jeden fall ganz witzig so finde
ich jetzt nicht schlimm oder so gut
dieses bild ist schon etwas fragwürdig
das ist das alter
i also ich finde deine zähne schlimm
aber am schlimmsten finde ich eigentlich
seine augenbrauen sowie gehen wir zurück
auf google und haben hier noch als
nächstes haben wir was ich auch kann ich
mir nichts darunter vorstellen ipad wie
hieß das noch mal mit sex and have sex
with your ipad alles klar
so wie gucken aber bilder ach du scheiße
ach du scheiße gibt es leute die auf
ipads stehen ja ich weiß so fürst ist
jetzt obwohl okay was ich mir auch
vorstellen könnte wäre wenn man auf dem
ipad eine ganz bestimmte sache guckt als
männlicher zuschauer und dann halt das
ipad ich stelle mir das rad einfach so
vor sowie wieder jemand auf diesem ipad
eine wie jemand auf diesem ipad
irgendeine frau hat und das passt halt
genauso von der position her und der
bewegt inhalt das ipad so was kommt lass
es lieber alex was für eine scheiße
erfunden wird ehrlich was wer kommt auf
so einen dreck so was gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch fürs iphone so das
lässt sich jetzt erstmal direkt iphone 6
segment nee das enttäuscht mich sogar
obwohl was ist das hier guck mal hier
dass das hier vielleicht kann man dass
wir irgendwie da hinten dran schrauben
kann ja sein
so kommen wir zum nächsten teil das
nächste gold was mir geschickt wurde war
groß bei denen kann ich mir jetzt
erstmal nichts darunter vorstellen wir
können ja mal gucken was heißt bading
rose oder wenn bis zum rosa angehen
trottas rosa naja an logisch was weiß
ich nicht alles weiß
ich glaube das muss ich zensieren
dieses bild das habe ich euch jetzt
ach du scheiße ich bin also nicht sehen
was ist das alter des teenie weg hier
ich will dir etwas ist keine ahnung
irgendwie findet man nichts aber ich
kann mir irgendwas drunter vorstellen
das will ich jetzt in diesem video nicht
erwähnt geht mir einfach mal zum letzten
punkt über uns war es der letzte punkt
kein job karaoke was ich an sich erst
mal klar
es deutet auch etwas hin aber so was
kann eigentlich nicht sein ich mein
bestes geben symphonies tv-show fanshop
karaoke kann auch nur aus dem raum
irgendwie asien oder sonst woher kam ist
klar ohne scheiß wenn uns nicht
irgendein video kommt wo irgend so ein
japan esel was sinkt während er
befriedigt wie kriegt jeder von euch von
mir fünf euro pro m 5 euro ist zu viel
gg
ich hab keinen bock mehr
ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht mehr warum
werfen ist toll sich sowas anzugucken
ich verstehe das nicht ja ich würde
sagen für heute reicht es wirklich erst
mal klar ihr könnt mir natürlich unter
dieses video weitere kommentare
schreiben was ich noch mal so google
sollte was man eventuell besser nicht
tun sollte dann google ich das in den
nächsten zwei drei wochen vielleicht
nochmal umgebung gibt es noch eine
ausgabe an uns meinte gefallen hat du
hast mir auf jeden fall nach oben da
dann sehe ich das und dann weiß ich ach
ihr wollt noch eine zweite folge weil
sowas ist natürlich immer lustig okay
für euch ist ja eigentlich genauso
lustig wie für mich obwohl nicht da
jetzt einige sachen zensiert habe weil
die musste ich glaube ich zum ball weil
die musste ich glaube ich zensieren
sonst wird dieses video ab 18
freigegeben und das möchte ich natürlich
vermeiden ansonsten das waren seine
videos dazu sind sie als anwender
abonniert vergessen um diesen maßen wir
sehen uns dann am nächsten freitag
wieder oder am nächsten donnerstag
morgen wir sehen uns donnerstag wieder
glaube ich wenn ich da nicht ich habe
jetzt gerade eine abi phase also so
feiern die stars und er verwendet und
das mache ich immer miteinander
haut rein denn